Why does Chemotherapy Causes Hair to Fall
Out?
It has to do with how different types of Chemotherapy
target cancer cells.
There are many different Chemotherapy drugs
that work in different ways, so I will only
speak in general terms regarding their side
effects.
Most cells in the human body divide using
a process called mitosis.
This process has 5 phases (prophase, prometaphase,
metaphase, anaphase, and telephase).
It is preceded by interphase, and results
in the cell dividing, called cytokinesis.
When a cell reaches the end of its lifespan,
it gets destroyed in a pre-programed process
called apoptosis.
There are many types of cancer (over 200).
All types are a result of the same problem,
unregulated cell growth.
The result is excessive tissue, known as tumors.
These tumors can be localized, or they can
spread to surrounding areas through your lymphatic
system or your blood stream.
Many Chemotherapy drugs work by interrupting
mitosis.
Most Chemotherapy cannot differentiate between
abnormal cancer cells and normal healthy cells.
Because of this, cells that have high mitotic
rates (multiply rapidly) can also be affected
by Chemotherapy- cells like those found in
your hair follicles, the lining of your mouth,
stomach, and those found in your bone marrow.
The result can be hair loss, decrease in production
of white blood cells (thus why cancer patients
are immune-suppressed), and inflammation of
your digestive tract.
In the end, chemotherapy will hopefully kill
the cancer cells, and in the process, unfortunately,
potentially cause hair loss.
However, the healthy cells of your hair follicles
will repair themselves, making your hair loss
temporary, as is hopefully
your cancer!